des notes de musique la scène nationale
d'équinoxe n'en avait pas entendu depuis
près de cinq mois
ce matin ce joueur de vielle à roue
enregistre sa musique pour la soirée
ciné concert du festival sans public
le son spectateur moi j'essaie quand
même de considérer qu'ils sont là c'est
à dire que lorsque je vais donner c'est
à dire qu'il ya la partition on les
oublie ya un moment on est vraiment
plongés dans le film je rajoute des
choses que je pensais pas jouer
peut-être qu'en public effectivement il
y aurait peut-être un lâcher prise que
j'essaye de retrouver au fur et à mesure
des choses pour retrouver les conditions
d'un spectacle vivant l'équipe du
festival retour vers le futur a fait
appel à un réalisateur
grâce à ces trois caméras il filme la
performance du musicien pour réaliser un
montage avec le film projeté
l'enjeu c'est de se mettre à la place du
spectateur et d'équilibré la vision du
film est la vision de l'artiste qui joue
à youri pour retrouver un peu le côté
live qui a dans une salle de gym
on a décidé de faire tout le tout la
prise en une seule prise tout le film en
une seule fois sans faire de montage de
coupe
le thème cette année la famille au
programme des séances de films sur une
plateforme unique et trois soirées live
sur facebook et youtube
beaucoup de changements donc car le mot
d'ordre cette année tout faire pour ne
pas annuler la quinzième édition
il s'était pour nous pas du tout évident
en fin de compte de d'imaginer un
festival en ligne parce que c'est
presque opposés à ce qu'on fait
habituellement
habituellement on invite les gens à
sortir de chez eux pour venir dans nos
dans nos salles et là on va s'inviter
dans l'est dans les foyers mais en
maintenant s'est dit que c'était
l'occasion d'expérimenter des choses
d'apprendre des d'apprendre des choses
et de vivre des choses inédites
et donc on y va avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé pour les soirées live
aucune inscription n'est demandée les
séances quant à elle coûte 4 euros
clap de fin le mardi 30 mars
[Musique]